we French know the truth the best food
in the world is met in Homs Franco
philic propaganda is scored by an
overture about Russia's victory over the
French army confused yet also animal
narration first of all I'm a rat which
means life is hard that's rat system I
have a highly developed sense of taste
and smell but what is it that led to
Remy's nose being so good it can't be
his love of food alone it has to be a
genetic reason or explanation right
turns out that funny smell was rat
poison suddenly dad didn't think my
talent was useless I agree that it was
sudden it was only 30 seconds ago that
you were telling me about your talent
and your dad not respecting it now here
we are and yes that was fast we gotta
cook this now exactly how we cook this
is the real question
where are the rats only hanging around
this warm house is it really enough to
sustain an entire colony how the hell is
this one elderly woman producing so much
garbage you think that maybe we
shouldn't be so mother nature goes could
easily and these rats get blasted off a
roof and into the plot propelling
situation also holy they survived that
she's gonna wake up these guys tasted a
thing and then decided it needed only
saffron to be perfect then realized this
lady had saffron I think then decided to
steal her saffron so they could
experience the perfect bite and honestly
this convoluted reasoning is flimsier
than most Bugs Bunny cartoons you read
not sure if I should be more shocked at
Remy reading or the brother only just
now realizing Remy can read or even
knowing what reading is and the duck a
hot head chef died shortly afterwards he
got his first bad review then literally
died from it how sensitive was this dude
I've gotten hundreds of thousands of bad
reviews a few dozen hate mails and two
separate hand-drawn maps leading me to
dangerous locations but none of them has
caused me to die as sadness somehow
pulling the trigger on this gun opens
the umbrella that's stuck in the barrel
because movie frequently forgets out of
physics also seriously the sight of a
couple rats causes granny to immediately
reach for the shotgun she'd rather
destroy her house at a rain of fire than
say grab a broom
Dan this old lady gun stores more
impossible shells than an action movie
villain
if these rats were all living in this
woman's attic before now that was not
made clear so Remy felt his dish needed
saffron and he robbed the old lady's
house for which caused a chain reaction
that led to the entire rat clan being
washed away all the way to Paris and
none of that has ever addressed again
the movie wanted to get everyone to
Paris and decided to show it to us but
it meant nothing no one is mad at Remy
when they meet up later on
everyone adjusts fine to Paris I suppose
the old lady was snatched up by the e
u--'s version of Medicaid and was
probably lost or killed via negligence
but this whole opening is pretty
meaningless how the hell is that book
readable after taking that long-ass trip
in the storm sewer my copy of Fifty
Shades of Grey was ruined after I walked
through the ring for one block holy did
movie just seriously yada-yada this
confrontation at gunpoint
is this a regular occurrence in Paris
man Francis weird the sequence of the
camera following Remy as he explores
Paris is awesome really worthy of a sin
removal but it makes me wonder how the
hell Remy knows exactly where to go at
all times when I'm ever stopping to see
which way to turn all this time
underneath Harris movie inadvertently
writes the most salacious Gilmore Girls
fan fiction ever also luckily for Remy
on the plot he emerged directly on a
perfect view of the city to confirm his
location I mean it's better than an
obvious title card but still to Stowe's
you've led me to your restaurant
lottery odds I mean here is a rat that
loves Gusteau's cookbooks and suddenly
finds himself swept into Paris and right
to the doorstep of Gusteau's and this is
so unrealistic that Justice League must
a scheme sent a congratulatory fruit
basket I was my mother she died that's
right kids we've killed off two
characters in the first 20 minutes of
this movie Jesus even died hard didn't
have this body count so soon you've read
my book left to see how much you know
huh
which one easy shape this entire scene
of Remy identifying all the various
kitchen workers all very important is
purely expositional later on this ghost
is gonna tell Remy he's not real and
Remy is talking to himself so he's just
proving to himself here how smart he is
but mostly he's letting the audience
know movie notwithstanding it takes a
kitchen full of employees ignoring an
entire station for several minutes in
order for this magical plot propelling
soup to even begin to get made in the
first place which is even more damning
since Remy pointed out that this was a
saucier his workstation where does
saucier go huh extended cigarette break
no wait this is France also linguini
grabs this piping hot pot of soup with
no ill effects I guess he does have
talent in the kitchen I mean I could say
this at virtually any point in this
movie
but how do all these assholes not notice
this obvious rat and a scene gets
dangerously close to a bad Tom and Jerry
episode some rat dude all and Queenie
did was add some water garlic and leeks
to the soup so why is it immediately
nauseating without so this act is
meaningless even more so for rats than
humans rats carry the plague guys he
dumps that entire container of broth
into his soup without any spills or
issues even though the movie already
showed this soup was nearing the top of
its container and would definitely
overflow if a gallon of broth were
poured on it
what are you playing act I'd like to
point out that this guy is basically the
primary villain in this movie but even
he just immediately admits and accepts
at this soup is wrath and a true asshole
would have called it disgusting and
refused to ever let Lin Greene cook
again instead this guy knows the super
rules but he can't accept the fact that
linguini cooked it because he didn't
this guy gets a bad rap I'm sending this
movie for not making this villain more
villainy also I'm pretty sure a simple
security camera would solve almost all
this movies conflict saucier would get
fired for abandoning his station and
linguini would keep his job as garbage
boy once everyone saw the rat was the
one that messed with the soup done and
done
this is a modern movie right and one of
the most famous high-end expensive
restaurants in Paris but no cameras not
even to safeguard the expensive wines
and other high-end ingredients
responsibly
I guess linguini trained at the esteemed
Mario Batali culinary school it's this
how you keep a restaurant at four stars
there's literally only a swinging
Dumbledore separating you and the
customers and you are screaming wait
when did he punch a triangular air hole
in this lid and why and does he just
carry a can opener on his person at all
times have you been nodding
Remi can understand English but he can't
speak and we're all speaking English
even though were in Paris movie
yada-yada is over the solution to the
language barrier here so hard that even
six-year-olds came out asking their
parents what the hell was going on I
can't cook
Canha awesome so we've immediately
undermined the central premise of the
movie by determining our secondary
protagonist is unable to do what gusto
says anyone can do hey they like the
soap they like the soup
linguini fell into the goddamn Seine
River survived it found the jar that
Remi was in rescued him and climbed out
of the Seine in record time why can't we
see that story this uncoordinated asshat
keeps losing jobs and can't do anything
and has no money and lives
this tiny cramped apartment and you
expect me to believe he takes up
valuable kitchen shelf space with a
goddamn soccer ball okay back the beep
beep beep this whole apartment has this
view and this failure of a citizen can
afford it good thing they both got a
good night's sleep last night instead of
trying to figure out any sort of plan
for pulling off the ruse today we ate
the soup take as much time as you need
oh we couldn't Skinner just a man the
recipe or if he wanted to keep linguini
honest wouldn't just stand here and
watch him make it this is the culinary
version of a Bond villain leaving him to
die without doing it himself
no one overhears linguini screaming at
the top of his lungs about the rat he
brought into the restaurant and before
you say that he's in the walk-in and it
would be soundproof I'll remind you the
Jack Torrance was able to easily
communicate with multiple people outside
of it in the shiny I'm just
familiarizing myself with vegetables
what'd I get you know this is actually a
pretty good adult joke suddenly thrown
into a kid's movie but it also means
that at some point Skinner definitely
stuck a cucumber up his ass the whole
rest of the movie kind of hinges on this
but this is a bullet if something
suddenly pulled two strands of your hair
the last thing you would do is raise
both arms in unison with said hair
strands this takes so long to learn I'm
surprised it's not snowing outside
already fun gratulations you were able
to repeat your accidental success this
is verbatim what my college girlfriend
said to me after our second time having
sex
gusto makes Chinese bored GI I haven't
seen marketing this blatantly racist
since H&M s last campaign also I never
understood this just because he became
head chef at this restaurant and even if
he owns the restaurant how did gusto
dying transfer the gusto lightness
rights to this offer there are only two
way to get first pick Oh Giselle
accidentally witness loosens we deal
tell then chef linguini has prepared
something special and falls endless I'm
saying definitely off menu I mean I know
Skinner's trying to get linguine in
trouble but he's throwing the entire
restaurant under the bus to do it and
why would he want him out anyway his
lawyer just told him it's better to keep
an eye on him while he's on the staff
okay I've held it in as long as I can
the wait Brad Bird greets Linguini's
physical comedy is perfection and it's
worth two sins off dammit
look I'm sure this is a great dish but
the entire restaurants gonna order the
same thing just based on looks it looks
like a goddamn pancreas covered in a
brown sauce it's kind of amazing rummy
shadow hasn't betrayed him before now it
is the City of Lights what I can't
believe is that Remmy is anywhere near
the colony considering the sewer split
up just after I left the countryside so
there would be no way they'd both end up
in Paris especially anywhere near each
other
Remmy he's just now stealing what about
all that linguini gave him for dinner
you ever had the fat fried snow did you
work in the lab right no I was linguini
this cool if I'm keeping his secret he's
a wreck in the best of circumstances and
if he's drunk he would totally spill the
beans hey why did they call it that blot
ratatouille roll rodents
I am deeply and truly offended by these
musical instruments come with me I got
something I want you to see you better
come take a look at this cliche what
kind of shop would advertise their rat
traps with actual dead and rats hanging
in the window is this an effective
strategy like the customers walk by and
say well I was just gonna let those
fellows live but I guess if those traps
are that good I've gotta bite one also
is this really an entire store that
dedicated to killing rats this works
even while he's sleeping even in a movie
about an English understanding Michelin
star worthy rat chef in Paris this
linguine doesn't wake up crap is asking
too much of my suspension of disbelief
you're hard to talk to you you don't
have to talk at all if you're that
committed to telling Colette the truth
just take off your fucking hat awesome
glad to see this badass female chef
eventually fall for a forced kiss
seriously maybe you could have left this
love story out with no difference to the
overall movie I realize you have a
little coffin imagery going on and
that's fun but who would build a room
like this there's nothing on any of
these side walls but sound reducing
panels there's no functional reason for
the size or shape of this office which
suggests the character just left coffins
and wanted a coffin office and that
takes the fun out of the imagery much
like the way I take the fun out of
movies rat with hair and linguini with
willpower fight over the use of his arm
I originally wrote that as a description
of the footage somewhere editors would
know what I wanted here but then I
realized it perfectly summed up why this
is stupid and annoying I mean does
linguini not realize that his hat fell
off does he not care I know he's in love
and but he also knows that Remi is the
sole reason for
success hey Rebbe are you doing the
entire movie has been telling us that
the rat clan doesn't give a shit about
what they eat and that Remi was the only
outlier so why would there be a big
demand from the other rats about trying
ramiz food microwave burritos or to a
second chicken you know a 15% of this
movie is Remi talking to figments of his
imagination
why would when Queeny be filed with your
will this used to be my office classic
not answering the question
you know when you get down to it right -
doing is just an expanded episode of
those are you the dad episodes on
mooring it takes this long for a
motorized scooter to catch up with a
goddamn rat but why not just stay on the
roof there's no way for Skinner to get
up there and this is a boat it's really
nowhere to go I know this is an
interesting story but it's the ownership
of a local restaurant really dominating
front-page news
how about promoting the dock worker
strike that seems important why the hell
wouldn't Remi just ask linguine for the
food for his family he's the new owner
now right they could supply the whole
clan for very little overhead I find her
being a terrible floppy awkward skater
and linguine aka pratfall Jones being
smooth as butter on skates to be one of
this movie's biggest and most insulting
reaches some part of me just knew the
gusto part Remi will now grab a tuft of
hair on the left side of Linguini's body
but it will cause Linguini's right arm
to make a movement this is probably done
because the right hand happens to be on
the left side of his body right now and
it makes more visual sense to the viewer
this way but it's definitely wrong as
far as how the movie has shown this dork
I will return tomorrow night with high
expectations why do you give linguini
the heads up isn't the whole thing with
food critics that they sneak up on you I
thought they even wore disguises and
you're stealing food how could you I
thought you were my friend geez how many
times we have to see the characters
fight over a contrived reason before the
movies climax cliche Solan queen he's
having nightmares about egos visit
because you know he and the rat are on
the outs and somehow despite having
physically done all the acts of cooking
and watching it all with his eyeballs he
apparently never picked up any actual
know-how
tell him to hit me with his best shot
never a good look for a critic to set
his opinion prior to experience and the
thing he's here to critique this would
be like Leonard Maltin strolling into a
screening of Ant Man and the wasp
barking out oh let's get this over with
I would have whatever he is having um
this disguise and fake voice would not
fool a single person that works here at
the restaurant where this guy was the
boss for a long time
how does this get solved if the car
isn't conveniently parked under several
freestanding gargoyles I realize France
has a lot of gargoyles compared to
America at least but goddamn are they
everywhere these are the most convenient
gargoyles ever and Disney made a movie
with gargoyles that were sentient I
seriously think Betty Crocker has a
solid copyright infringement case
against the publishers of Gusteau's
cookbook they use blue instead of red
and added some fleur-de-lis but in terms
of design elements it's an open-and-shut
case
holy the students of raw as deal in this
movie getting punished just for doing
his job he's treated worse than David
Paymer in Ocean's thirteen maybe the
rats will break a slot machine or
something as compensation at the end of
the movie
cute visual but again the problem with
rats in the kitchen isn't literal dirt
its disease in bacteria but whatever
this moment is the best of Pixar
encapsulated pure joy for the character
translates as pure joy for the viewer
see illumination you don't have to rely
on fart jokes in a kid's movie once and
off the following day his review appears
Jesus he was there until after closing
no way a dude that old works on a
deadline that early in anyways the work
of a critic is easy damn this is our
third narrator in this movie we thrive
on negative criticism which is found to
write and read dude just unknowingly
wrote our mission statement well we had
to let Skinner in the health inspector
loose and somehow never encountered any
legal or ethical issues for abusing and
imprisoning them haha what a ripping
good yarn that abduction story is ha ha
ha which one would you like surprised me
and rats were never considered vermin
again and swarmed into kitchens around
the world the end
I got this read this knowing GED all
right
what I say is true it rubs the lotion on
its skin or else it gets the hose again
pure poetry that without looking and
humbled into the Sun yeah my baking
tastes good
porkchops taste good Hey sewer rat meat
tastes like pumpkin pan but I never know
cuz I wouldn't need to fill him up just
make me fail your pile in a sadness Bowl
that's what I want
chill dad gave me a job why am I the
poop checker dreaming salty sweet and
oaky nuttiness
it was jammy plumbing dense and chewy as
a cinema since van you clearly know a
thing or two about high-quality
entertainment thought have you ever
considered working in the entertainment
industry a job in entertainment is about
what you know and who you know at Full
Sail you'll not only gain knowledge and
hands-on experience but you'll also
connect with other students and
successful grants full sale is committed
to hands-on education that means going
beyond sitting in a classroom and
flipping through a technical it means
putting yourself in real-world scenarios
because that's how you learn the skills
you'll actually use on the job you can
study online or attend their sunny
Florida campus
best of all Full Sail offers accelerated
degree programs
the sooner you graduate the sooner
you'll get a chance to kickstart your
career and put your education to work
full sales specializes in entertainment
media technology and the arts this blend
has produced a community of inspired and
creative people who push each other to
do amazing things
Full Sail grants helped engineer
kendrick lamar's latest record animates
Steven Spielberg's latest movie and
design the latest Call of Duty game if
you've got the dream and the drive one
day we could be sitting your moves go to
Full Sail edu slash cinemasins to learn
more
[Music]